he that was goaltending
on that follow-up
three seconds to go curry from d knocks
it down with a second to go
there you go
holiday from half court keeping golden
state in the game chris middleton is the
leading scorer for milwaukee he's the
biggest reason the bucks lead curry and
the warriors by 10. he started in the
middle he flashed to the middle and he
just backed up and no one went with him
and he's like oh no one's here i'm gonna
shoot oh my goodness hurry with a three
shot the clock was running down i mean
there is such a preoccupation with the
three right now in the nba
like two passes will get you a dunk
against most teams exactly a lot of bigs
are shooting threes now trying to expand
their game
derek jones jr is just trying to make
sure he doesn't give him any air space
how about a little spin move he knew
derek jones jr was just in recovery mode
he's like i gotta get back out there
that's too good of a move he lost me let
me get back in front of this dude and
curry he's like up
gotcha
shot fake jump right back into
curry
miller trying to get his hands on him
steph
being ridden by lillard the whole time
he put it in again
he has hit two circus shot runners for
an opportunity for another three-point
play and this is against damian lillard
oakland's own behind the back
and david lillard
moved his feet he wasn't lost
but you wonder behind the back step had
him on his side and just use that to his
advantage use his body momentum against
him leaned on him a little bit
man steph just steph is running into the
front court draymond finds him another
three
[Applause]
and he actually surpasses his buddy clay
thompson
they're looking forward to draymond
green of course his boy where's he at
where's he at handoff that is a tough
shot too gary trent right at him he's
not left-handed but he's almost
ambidextrous when it comes to his
finishing and curry's got 18 now as he
hits the three they just left him they
just fell asleep
lubray
had to pick up the dribble curry cut
without the ball behind the back to
looney to lay it up and in that's one
for the highlight reel
out the ball mr lethal ubra good drive
two defenders go with him they don't see
man in ball always got to know where
steph curry is he's always moving and mr
in the right place at the right time
kavon looney yeah corey joseph you just
get caught ball watching just for a
second
how about the reaction did he go goggle
brogden driving
and looney did just enough
it's definitely free air space his three
is good
we press the duke button
and then just handles holiday
couldn't do anything about it fake and
drive by paul millsap with 12. he leads
denvering scoring
three
what a shot
[Applause]
there's just no words i mean
and easily could have been a four-point
play right i mean you gotta allow the
you gotta allow the shooter to come down
right
right now the warriors 24th and
offensive rating as uber
fires it down
private hesitation here
oh beautiful hesitation there by steph
to set up ubere and ba you're absolutely
right you know think about this warriors
team over the last five or six years
they were one of the most efficient
offensive
[Applause]
oh curry was going to pull back
flip to wiseman
oh get ready to watch that the next
couple years the angle of this step
loses it by murray pretty easily
aldridge has to come over just throw it
up a little no look one for the
highlight reel put some sauce on it
nice remember the last couple games
denver and indiana the warriors were
trying all these
wrap around bounce 22 you'll live with
him making that
steph cutting back door three knicks on
him these are the open shots and
draymond rails it yeah randall went down
there with steph and that back door
draymond was ready
and
tom thibodeau was the coach
and that was in chicago and so draymond
is going to get warm up three
definitely use that wiseman screen
go bears there to make sure he doesn't
finish curry
is now second all time there he goes the
2
51.
that's bully ball there but watch steph
give it up as soon as he gives it up
he's sprinting
to that corner colleen's like oh no i've
seen this before
he's a keeper and what you want to do as
a coach is tell him don't tease me this
is the way you've got to play every
single night
oh curry with a ridiculous breakdown in
the quarter and mark this one was an
incredible handle
says allow kimball walker
no and green taps it to curry
warriors have missed six of their last
seven during this run curry oh my
goodness what a finish by stefan curry
one for curry brilliant
yeah sometimes ba you just got to let it
breathe man
[Applause]
just let it breathe this play just
speaks volumes for itself and you know
only down if he makes this down seven
[Applause]
curry way downtown bang steph curry from
just inside half court
unbelievable that's his ninth
three-pointer of the game already second
chance points too we'll be watching that
shot clock is off
steph down to two stops he backs all the
way up oh no
that is almost unfair the game has been
broken
curry kind of weaving through traffic oh
what a look
steph curry got to communicate that one
this was a really high ball screen from
draymond and if i asked you how many
years he played in kentucky one much to
your cigarette that was it
oh
make that he changed his how did he make
that like he surprised himself you know
you're doing some of your stuff and
you're surprised look i'm gonna pass it
out wait a minute let me just flip this
off
what was that he draws the foul here so
he heard the whistle oh 180 and then
flipped it in who who does that
he's not from here
he's different
it's about
curry
working against none
lets the three go scores it steph with a
huge dagger point shooting night mark
5 foot 23 from the field the question is
how many shots did he miss when it
matters most the answer none
steph curry over kendrick nunn for the
knock down dagger shot mama here goes
that man
steph tried to sneak it inside good
defense nerlie's noelle behind the back
to looney
and very patient he's getting kind of
stapled knowledge to well to the ground
but this is the creativity from steph
okay what do i do here two defenders
around me let me just wrap it around my
back kevon lewis like should i pass this
out no that's too good of a pass i gotta
go up and finish and get my guy this
assist
look do i pass it to it no no one's
there
a minute remaining here in the third
quarter
curry inside looking to draw the foul
and it goes in now the top of the
backboard is in did it hit anything else
chance for a three-point play
finished by steph curry the question is
did it go off on the top
for the young fella
here's steph from the corner wide open
there you go
way to listen to your
and the greatest shooter this game has
ever seen
the shot the turnaround the little
shimmy listening to his head coach c
webb
lebron
[Applause]
not fair please it's not fair
you're such a big reason why this game
has changed but it's changed about 10
feet up from
steph curry back in there
curry
tries to backtrack
and fires from near come on again
come on man see the whole sequence look
at this is good defense okay pressure
ball he loses it look he laughs he
laughs and then just says okay
the paul will
inbound a 17-2 run
[Applause]
by team lebron
most threes and a half seven by russell
westbrook and by kawaii here's number
seven
anything you can do
i can do better mr lillard
and here's curry firing away
return home just for a couple of days
and then hit the road again for a
five-game roadie
and atlanta in their first home game
since the middle of march look at stiff
showing the handle
in his midst another look
i mean the fact that you can't see
another defender
green goes to the basket gives it up
ubrae for three ubrae in and out
and look at wiggins the effort to run it
down curry three-pointer for stephen
curry
bone
injured
comes right back wiggins kept it alive
curry the warriors played the dean it
was wiggins doing it wiggins on the
sprint out and did well to catch that
john wall said not curry behind his back
flip it up and in draw the foul showtime
here yes he did look you had warriors
run the floor what else is new
who else has this creativity kevin
porter jr comes over he's like let me go
behind the back to avoid him
[Applause]
will chamberlain we might be talking
about him having a 50 ball
i don't know how you shore it up i mean
he's making from everywhere now
he has two right there and back he knows
curry he knows just got himself the
record
and look when people talk about oh do
players pay attention no it's in the
back of their mind they know he's steph
curry knows and look
curry spins
step back trying to draw another foul
and it goes in
steph curry with a circus shot and the
foul
[Applause]
and steph dribbled it off his foot shot
clock at three
and curry gonna try to get one up from
way deep and laser it in of course
we've won stephen curry
behind the back buddy yields all over
him thought he was close enough
you are not
come on just rejected the screen you
want to force him to it the help's on
the other side you let him go the other
way it's gonna be easier for him old man
curry two for one and he drops in at
three
yo the unlimited range is bamboozling
everyone warriors have won seven of ten
can they make it eighth of 11 with steph
shooting like that perhaps
curry deep three got it with an
opportunity for a four-point play
from minnetonka this often
angela russell he's seen him do it a
million times even played with the guy
and he's still shocked
that he shot it from this far out he's
just got unlimited range mulder will
push find curry again
and basically is saying wait oh he
backed up on him and hit another three
baisley fell asleep he thought he did
his job
curry
for the lead
rattled it out
looney will track it down
steph one more time for the advantage
good
if at first you don't succeed you know
what they say
try try again
nobody it should have been gobert but
you got so much space look where
governor is
he's the only one that's supposed to be
guarding this screen
now kavon looney
has double digit rebounds in three
straight games he had never done that in
his career nine point lead and you sense
curry and the warriors moving in for a
little bit of a kill here steph in his
bag
deep
like the fries were at the bottom
the memphis grizzlies and it's what's
remarkable to me is how little he needs
the basketball to be successful it's a
pretty team to watch with the constant
movement and the passing